[Music]
Brad there's a break in the fence I
think there's some wild horse some
problem federal crime to feed a lot of
feral horses when you come off property
but no I can't do that they're gonna die
plain and simple you owe the bank just
north of six million dollars six million
dollar all money borrowed against the
ranch to keep it afloat and my family
for four generations versus
rehabilitation neckline program works
mostly with inmates incarcerated for
nonviolent reasons drugs theft fraud got
90 days get this or statement up with
similar back 25,000 ponies are gonna
pull this off we might convince the
breeders that we know what we're doing
hey man give me a view why I got to go
first thank god you're here
it's as bad as what daddy did they're
hurting me
these men may spend the night in jail
there may be guards all over the place
but when they're with these horses they
are free
[Music]
Meredith Parrish here's a few of my
babies my horses don't look anything
like this nobody takes care of him like
I do I am here to protect them at any
cost
so if you don't stop what you're doing I
will be forced to make an example out of
you she thinks of all horses should be
left to run free in the wild and she'll
take on anybody she fixes interfere
you're joking
I will destroy you
you